we are indeed with a Wonder Liang a
Wonder first of all congratulations a
very tense finish for you in this game
against Hans but a successful campaign
here at the USA championships yeah I
think the tournament overall went
um really well um by my standards and I
think I started out with this loss
against elshon in round two but after
that I went undefeated
um plus three with white so yeah really
way more than anything I could have
expected
um going in I just kind of want to
finish in the middle of the pack like
maybe with an even score but but yeah
somehow my opponents kept giving me
these chances and I didn't even like
take all of them but yeah I mean what I
had was was my best US championships
ever and like I don't know it's just
really quite surreal at this moment and
how is uh homework going on nowadays I
wonder did you catch up with your
schoolwork
um now where we had quite a bit but yeah
we can talk about that at a future time
right now I'd rather really rather not
think about no confessions it's too
depressing absolutely but your
professors must be quite happy with uh
the way you have performed here and you
were mentioning at the beginning of the
show when we had our first interview
that you were in close contact with some
of your professors right um I have a
professor friend that studies chess um
but unfortunately he's he's not one of
my professors in the classes I'm taking
so I haven't been getting a lot of slack
from from the professors that create my
work but uh but it's fine yeah how about
today's game uh Hans came up with this
idea of Queen to E2 did you expect this
or no yeah I mean I was I was quite
scared for today's game because I think
nepo had this observation that Hans
typically likes to announce his
comebacks before he makes them
um about three days ago he announced
that he was about to make a cutback that
I see he wins three in a row and I'm
like wait a minute like I played him in
the last round like what's what's going
on here and yeah I knew he just wanted
to get a big fight like I'm lower rate
than him and like okay what I think what
he got was probably not the greatest
position
um but basically he wanted to keep it
closed and avoid a lot of Trades I think
um
just like for this event like my
strategy has sort of been to keep the
positions relatively simple
um I think like in the whole term I've
probably only played like two or three
middle games actual middle games what's
my games go like straight to the end
game and I think it's helped me conserve
energy and just like I blunder less
um with you know with schoolwork and all
that so it's kind of my strategy going
into the tournament
um but here like I thought like okay his
position is so bad that like I don't
even care if um if it's like a
complicated middle game but I think like
his strategy really worked out because
yeah almost immediately I think maybe
yeah somewhere around the middle maybe
after F4 let's take a look at what yeah
okay uh I wonder you had we were talking
about you needed to make yeah I think
like this queen D7 Queen C7 was a little
sloppy first of all like probably even
Queen C7 immediately because I think F5
is not even such a big threat
and then
yeah I thought Pierre maybe we're back
you're back okay that was fast
um I thought here maybe yeah instead of
Queen D7 like okay I can just go Queen
C7 immediately instead of Queen
um all the way here yeah yeah and then
okay like she can do the same thing like
play Knight F3 but
um because I went like Queen D7 Queen C7
yeah and then yeah okay here I have like
F5 ideas or even like what I had in the
game with F6 is not so bad
um but I sort of just allowed his Knight
to come to E1 which I just missed and
yeah here yeah I definitely should have
just won Bishop F7 or something like
this um after 94. at least it's more
consistent with my plan and the idea is
like F5 G5 I lock up
um or if he goes F5 then I have G5
Knight F3 B5 and I think I'm quite fast
on the queen side yes at least this was
kind of my impression it feels awesome
yeah
okay it's quite complicated I was
feeling good here um but yeah after G5
like okay he looked at me a little funny
like okay it's kind of typical for him
to do it I realized like oh crap he has
a style of five and yeah yeah sort of
yeah it was kind of a nightmare because
like I wasn't focusing so well
throughout this event and basically I
just immediately blundered
um yeah and here again I thought I
should go Bishop H7 instead of Bishop G6
was probably played decent okay yeah
again like I didn't realize that one was
fine as well yeah yeah I think not a big
uh change okay I didn't see if Bishop
takes D3 that's actually a horrendous
Miss but I think right yeah it's been
quite typical of my play this event
where like I think I'm quite fine if the
position is very simplified like we get
into some sort of end game
um but yeah and these games like my form
is is really just terrible like I'm
blundering everything which you guys
kind of did at this point right but yeah
here here I kind of felt like I was fine
like there's quite a bit of compensation
for the pawn and
yeah I mean it's it's a normal position
like I think with the two Bishops I
thought even I could get a little
ambitious but yeah we just trade
everything and I think he defended this
well and then okay I had to find some
background moves and it was more or less
normal
I wonder congratulations uh for your
performance guys any questions for a
wander uh yes well first of all again uh
congratulations to you I wonder I
watched you struggling at the U.S junior
Champion you come in as the wild card
and you play like you belong
what was the difference between your
play in the U.S junior and your playing
the U.S Championship you played really
good here yeah no I think there's kind
of a few big differences I think in the
Juniors
um I first of all I had five blacks and
like a lot of my black games were
against some of the stronger players and
I really felt like I needed to push in
those games and
it was it was quite difficult because
like some of these Juniors like that
they're really strong and I learned that
the hard way unfortunately
um of course I had like my fair share of
blunders but I think yeah in the Juniors
I sort of didn't really come in with the
right strategy
um I was playing all these very
complicated middle games
um some of them I was getting tactically
outplayed and some of them like I just
blundered
um really badly in the late stage and
here I thought like I don't really feel
like I'll have enough energy to play
really long games every game or just
like these complicated positions where I
need to think a lot and
I decided like I made some changes to my
opening reporter so like first of all
um with white I had like several
contingencies just in case there was
school work or I was really busy like
basically I couldn't force a draw with
white against any player
um and with black like basically yeah I
wanted to make sure that like I kept it
really simple
um as I said like a lot of end games a
lot of very simple chests so that like I
knew that in these sort of complicated
positions that I have a tendency to just
blunder a lot just because I'm quite
Rusty and you know like mentally I don't
I didn't feel like I would have enough
energy especially late in the tournament
um but yeah what ended up happening in
this event at least was was yeah most of
my I think I outprepared my opponents in
nearly every game and I got like the
simplified positions that I thought felt
like I could play really well and yeah
luckily you know I managed to avoid at
least the worst blenders I think in
especially some of the late games
um I did start blundering a little bit
but yeah the positions were well within
the boundary days of at least equality
so it didn't end up that badly sounds
like you really did a lot of work on
your openings and you got you achieved
the type of positions you wanted
Anastasia any questions for a Wonder or
great performance yes yes I just wanted
to ask which game you are proud of the
most after this event which gave you
like the most
yeah probably the game gets Fabiano I
think is basically my best game of the
event I mean obviously I made plenty of
mistakes but it's
it's like it's probably been the most
difficult it was the most difficult game
of my life because like just the amount
of pressure that you face
um even like I got like all my
preparation basically and like the
engine said like triple zeros after it
so I was like okay like uh with this pet
Drop Like It's amazing
um but but like then you start to feel
like you know these 2750 2800 guys like
they put so much pressure and like just
to be able to defend that position for
so long and after five five six hours
like that's probably the best game I've
ever played in my life even I mean not
just not like from an objective
standpoint but just like
I mean like it's hard to describe like
when you're like sitting across the
board from this guy like it's just so so
intense
um it's like the most difficult game
I've ever played
um and I was definitely lost at some
point or like several points
um but yeah even just to hold that like
I don't know after the game I felt so
tired I like I couldn't even like move
or anything like I just laid in my bed
for a few hours I had this like minor
headache oh it was just such a such a
tough game and yeah I was very glad that
I managed to hold that this is when you
play against Fabiana this is what
happens actually yes but I'm so
surprised and even kind of shocked that
you didn't pick up the game against
Levon but we picked this game yes it
also shows something let's say about the
way you think right yeah it was a good
game against Lavon but yeah again like
going into the tournament
um I had like four players which like I
was just trying to hold against and like
you know like Fabiano
um Lavon Wesley and Dominguez and I felt
yeah against Levon like basically I
played this very solid line and he could
have forced to draw but
um yeah okay he he over pushed basically
or he really felt like he wanted to get
a game so I don't feel like it's as much
of an achievement from my part just
because I don't know he like
yeah it was it was kind of a surprise to
win this game
um but against Fabiano like just
yeah I just felt so so tired after this
game like yeah it's probably really one
of the best games I've ever played okay
great thank you so much absolutely once
again our congratulations uh to you
under very very nice result indeed let's
jump uh immediately to the game of Ray
Rob